Amazing.
I think there's still some people coming
in toward the back. Um, so I'll do like
the quick maybe like uh administrative
stuff in the meantime. This is going to
be super interactive. Uh, there's also
like mics around, so if any at any point
you guys have questions, um, just raise
your hand. Um, someone will go to you or
I think we also have mics nearby. Um,
cool. I think that's pretty much it.
I'll let a few people finish trickling
in and then we'll get started.
Okay, I think that's long enough. Um,
okay. So, welcome everyone to model
maxing with OpenAI. Uh, we're going to
be talking about RFT, SFTD, DPO. My name
is Elan Behu. Uh I'm on the developer
experience team at OpenAI and so I do a
lot of very early testing on new
products and new directions that we're
taking the API. So whenever there's a
new feature coming out and it's still
changing like every day they're like can
you tell us how good this is? Uh and
make a demo with it. So this is a little
bit of what we're going to be doing
today. It's going to be a bit of a cross
between a presentation. If you've been
to any of my talks before, they're very
codeheavy. This one's a little bit less
so because it's fine-tuning and I don't
want to have you waiting for multiple
hours watching a progress bar. So, I
have a lot of like pre-ompiled data and
some stories to share. Um, cool. So,
this is you. Uh, you might be asking,
you know, SFT, RFT, DPO, what the heck
are all these letters? Uh, that's a
great question. You might have some
experience with fine-tuning, but be a
little bit more asking like, you know,
will fine-tuning solve all of my
problems? It's another good question.
Um, you might also be wondering if
you're you're in the right room. Uh, you
are most likely. If you want to learn
about fine-tuning, stay here.
Cool. So, yeah, we're going to be
talking about optimization at a high
level. Um, and then the specific subset
that is fine-tuning. We're going to go
into each of the different fine-tuning
options that OpenAI provides. Um, and
then some stories, examples, best
practices, and then we're going to do
some Q&A. Um, I think I have like 1 hour
and a half or two hours. I have no idea
how long this is going to take. We'll
take as long as we need. Uh if we end
early, you can all have some food. Uh
cool. So this is optimization. This is
everything that it is, right? It's like
it's a graph uh with a line going up and
to the right in some nonlinear path. Um
this is what you're going for whenever
we talk about optimization. Uh how you
actually accomplish this can vary a lot.
It can vary. Um, you know, you can do
like manual optimization, fine-tuning,
changing your prompt. There's a million
ways to do this in a million different
industries. But, uh, when you say
optimization, this is all it means.
Specifically, when it comes to LLM
optimization, we have a few different
ways we can do it. Um, but every LM
system is sort of composed of these
three uh events or parts, right? You
have your input, which involves the
prompt and the context. Um you have your
model which is the like actually
represented by the weights and whatever
was pre-trained. Um and then you also
have this system that goes around the
model. It's the scaffolding, it's the
tools. Um I will go ahead and say this
is every single LM application ever. Uh
so everything we say will cover all of
this. Now today we're going to be
focusing mostly on this middle part. Um
optimizing the weights and optimizing
the model choice. Now, how to optimize
like prompt context, like prompt and
context and tools and scaffolding.
There's like a million ways to do that.
Um, I think there's other talks today
that are going to go a little bit more
in depth into that, but we're going to
be focusing on this middle one. Um,
especially since it's a little bit
nebulous. Uh, and I want to help clarify
some of the topics and especially how
you can do it with um the different like
fine-tuning offerings that you can use
on the OpenAI platform. So, this might
be your initial reaction to fine-tuning.
It's like it's this like gross idea.
It's it's hard. It's confusing. um I
would rather just like write prompts uh
like this and have the model do what I
want. Now that's fair. I think for a lot
of for a lot of problems that's actually
the case. Um fine-tuning is really just
continued training that optimizes a
model for a given domain. So
it might be useful for your case. Um you
might be better off sticking up with
prompting and this is one of the things
that we're going to be talking about
today. But I think the idea is to open
up your eyes to like all the options
that you have.
So, let's do a quick comparison between
prompting and fine-tuning and then move
on. Um, prompting is kind of like a set
of tools like a hammer, um, pliers,
whatever. I think those are some madeup
tools in the back that don't exist, but
we're going to ignore those. Uh, it has
a very low barrier to entry. Anybody can
do it. Um, it's very easy and quick to
do small changes to like quickly
progress. Um, and it's actually enough
for I'd say most jobs. Now, fine-tuning
is like a CNC machine, right? you have
uh like it's a way higher upfront
investment. You have to collect data,
make sure it's clean. Um the iteration
loops are longer, right? Like you can't
just like make a quick tweak and like
rerun because the rerun is going to be
multiple hours. So um however, they're
more automated, right? Like if you have
a pipeline set up for fine-tuning, it's
a little bit more hands-off. You don't
have to do all this manual thinking
yourself. Um and finally, it is a
specialized tool, right? It's not useful
for every single use case, but there are
certain use cases where it really really
shines. Um, and with certain kinds of
fine-tuning, you can actually push the
boundary of what is possible and do
things prompting cannot accomplish.
So these are the three main types of
fine-tuning that we uh support during
OpenAI. If you're going to take
pictures, there's another slide later
that has this and more. Um, so the first
one is SFT, supervised fine-tuning. And
what is this? It's just imitation,
right? you just show uh the model what
you want it to output and it'll learn to
copy exactly that. The next one is
direct preference optimization and it's
about doing uh showing the model two
samples and you say one of them I don't
like, one of them I like, do it more
like the one I like and less like the
one I don't like. And then finally, we
recently introduced reinforcement
finetuning. Uh reinforcement
fine-tuning, which is actually like the
magic sauce that went into making 01 and
03 and 04 mini and all these reasoning
models. We like you can use this
algorithm as well on this platform. Um
and what you're doing, you're
essentially providing a way um the model
essentially figures out how to think
about your given problem. So let's get a
little bit deeper into each one. What
does the data for supervised fine-tuning
look like? Like I mentioned before, you
just collect a set of inputs and outputs
that you want. Um for direct preference
optimization, you have inputs and then
for each input you have a positive
output and a negative output. Um I think
we call them preferred and
non-preferred.
And then finally for reinforcement
fine-tuning, you provide a set of
inputs. Um, and then slightly
differently, you provide a greater. And
optionally with the inputs, you can
provide some reference in order for the
grader to be able to like have a ground
truth if you want. But really, this
greater can be one of a variety of
things that we're going to be talking
about later. Um, which is why um,
reinforcement fine-tuning is so powerful
because it it does not constrain what
you can do as much as these other two,
but it still has its caveats. So, we're
going to be going into all that. Now,
what do each of these cases learn?
Right? like you can look at the data,
maybe you have some idea. Um, but like
from first glance, there's a lot of
cases that supervised fine-tuning looks
like it might be able to do like direct
preference optimization versus
reinforcement fine-tuning. Like how do
you think about what each of them is
doing? And the way that I find it most
use most useful to think about this is
thinking about what is the model
learning in each of these cases. So
supervised fine-tuning is essentially
learning a continuous mapping or like a
soft mapping from your inputs to the
outputs. Um and so you know it it's it's
not exactly like a like a direct mapping
like a table but in essence that is what
you're teaching the model. It's very
very direct. Um it's just going to learn
to imitate the data that you provided.
Um direct preference optimization is a
little bit more interesting. um it
doesn't actually learn like each of the
examples, it learns the delta between
the examples. And so if you imagine if
you can like pull up your like mental uh
embedding like latent space and you
project these two ideas there um the
positive output and the negative output
um if you can imagine like what that
difference vector is between them that
is essentially what you're trying to
teach the model.
And then finally, and this is also it
looks straightforward, but it's actually
pretty interesting is learning to
reason, right? So reinforcement
fine-tuning learns to reason about a
problem by learning to tune and change
its chain of thought so that it is able
to get this like higher success rate on
whatever problem that you're giving it.
Um so what each what is each of these
good for? So supervised fine is the
simplest of the bunch. Um it's great for
classification use cases. Um, it's great
for formatting and structured data
extraction. Pretty much any case where
you really want to constrain what the
model is doing. Um, and have a very
specific kind of output, supervised
fine-tuning is it. And this is helpful
for like distillation. If you want to
teach like a very very very small model
how to do this like structured output
example and like prompting isn't cutting
it, supervised fine-tuning is the way to
go. Now, direct preference optimization
is a little bit more um I'd say it's the
hardest to think about of the three. Um
it's very good at learning tone
matching, right? Because tone and style
are these kind of little bit more um
intangible things that are harder to
evaluate but easy to see if you put two
uh comparisons together, right? Right.
And so this was really made um in order
to do tone matching and also um I mean
primarily it is when you have AB tests,
right? Like when you have uh positive
data and negative data, preferred data,
not preferred data. If you've been using
chatpt and you get like both like two
responses, this is why, right? Like this
is the algorithm that is being used in
order to like tune for those
preferences. And so it's not saying
output exactly the one that I prefer.
it's saying output slightly more in that
direction whereas supervised finetuning
is much more exact and then
reinforcement fine-tuning is for
gradable hard problems. Um some examples
are like medical legal coding just like
things that are pretty hard to do but
pretty simple or straightforward to
verify. Um you really really really want
unambiguous solutions and I feel like in
a lot of these talks we always talk
about successes. I snuck in a little
failure here later, so you're going to
get to see that. Um, and it's also a
really interesting candidate for
training an LLM judge model, right?
Because
grading a problem is actually a problem
itself. And so if you like grading that
problem is a pretty verifiable answer if
you have these like golden results that
you want your LLM judge to be able to
mimic.
Cool.
So, one thing to note before I get into
each of these is that um each of these
approaches while
they're very different, we are training
only a subset of the model in each of
these cases. And so this is why they're
not amazing for learning like tons of
new data, right? like rag um and other
solutions like agentic retrieval are
much much better if you want to teach
the model new information um this is
called uh I think low rank adaptation
can anybody check me on that yeah I see
some knots cool um and essentially for
those who are interested you should look
more into it's a really really clever
way where you take the model weights and
you decompose them into two matrices um
and then that essentially gives you a
much smaller set of weights that you
need to update in order to affect the
overall model behavior. And so you don't
fully readjust the entire model. You
don't make it forget the things it did
before, but you still impart some new
behaviors into it. Um, cool. So let's
start with a story. Um, when I joined
OpenAI, I was working as a solutions
architect. And what this meant was I was
working directly with companies helping
them deploy their like AI use cases and
applications into whatever um domains
they are working in. Now uh one of our
partners, one of our customers was
working on a low latency function
calling use case kind of assistant style
based on like taking action, right? And
so you would uh the user would say
something um and the the model had to
act um but it was in an extremely
latency constrained uh scenario right so
they wanted to use back then it was 3.5
GPT 3.5 um GPT 3.5 was very very fast um
but not very accurate uh GPT4 was
roughly the level of performance that
they were expecting in terms of accuracy
but it was way too slow uh and so they
asked us what can we do um
So, uh, ooh, actually before I get into
this, this would actually be fairly
straightforward. And I feel like a lot
of you could imagine how to do this if
we had a lot of existing examples with
like inputs and outputs. Um, which they
did not have. And so we were left to
figure out how do you fine a model when
you don't have like this this great
amount of data or or these like good
examples. Um, and so we took a few
different approaches, but I'm going to
cover the two main ones that we used
that proved to be pretty effective.
So the first one is we did have all of
the functions that they wanted the agent
to use. Um
one more thing I didn't say they were
trying to do this with 120 functions
which was unheard of at the time. I
remember asking um some researchers like
you know what is like uh how many do we
support usually and they were like yeah
five to 10 maybe like okay okay cool
cool. Um so this is actually the first
time that anybody fine-tuned a model
with over 100 functions because uh it
did the capability was not possible
before. We had to have this built for
this use case. Um so what you're seeing
here is the first step that we did. We
actually took the function uh schemas
that the customer provided
um and uh figured out a way to create
every possible like permutation of the
invocations of that function. So for
example, if we have like a toggle typo,
if we have like set lights uh and it
takes one parameter and it's an enum. Uh
here I'm essentially showing that the
three permutations that you can have are
set lights off, set lights on, and set
lights red. This was actually done
completely deterministically. This was
just like a a Python script um that I
spent way too long working on. Then uh
search song is kind of similar. Uh
there's more than one parameter here.
Here I skipped the cases where you
provide like multiple parameters. But
essentially what this function did is it
took a schema uh from a function and
then it spat out essentially every
possible permutation of that function.
Um and if it was like more if like it
exploded in complexity, we would like
randomly sample from from those.
Um so this was the first step.
Oh, and then if there were some samples
that were non-deterministic like KDP or
like were open-ended, we would ask a
model to like provide plausible values.
The next step was once we have those
function calls, then we asked GPT4 to go
essentially from here's a function call,
give me a command that would have
resulted in that function call. Um, and
we did this for a large number of the
permutations. Um, and so some of you
might already be noticing what we're
doing, but essentially if you like flip
this in your head, now we have these
input output pairs where the input is
the GPT4 generated command and the
output is the function call itself. So
we're already on a pretty good track,
right? We have a lot of data. Um, but
it's pretty it's it's synthetic and we
don't just want it to be synthetic. We
don't know if these are the kinds of
inputs that the users will be giving and
if we are very off base, if we are like
very out of distribution, we won't have
as good um of a model in the end. I will
say the models are pretty good at
generalizing even if you do stuff that
is slightly out of distribution because
they have such a large set of weights in
like a pre-existing world model.
The second way we did it was distilling
some data. Um, so, uh, the engineers we
were working with did actually have, um,
some unlabeled inputs, and we were like,
okay,
well, here's what you said. GPD4 was
good enough for most of these cases. So,
let's do something. Uh, let's just run
them through GPT4 and get what outputs
GPD4 would give us. Um, after this, I
didn't include this in here, we actually
did some filtering as well. And like we
did a couple stages in this pipeline to
essentially generate a lot of like
distilled um still still uh synthetic
data but uh hopefully very high quality.
And in the end we took these two data
sets uh pass them into GPT 3.5
um and we achieved GPT4 level
performance at 3.5 accuracy. Um and so
this was one of the first like major
successes that I saw with supervised
fine-tuning. Now, note that this is a
very constrained use case. So, it's
actually perfect for fine-tuning. The
model doesn't have to do this like
open-ended response. You're not trying
to strive for a certain personality. You
just want it to call one function, and
you want it to do it well, and you want
it to do it fast. So, this is a perfect
use case to do distillation with
supervised fine-tuning.
Actually, I want to keep this
interactive. I'll pause every now and
then. Feel free to ask any questions. If
I don't see any hands, I'll just like
barrel along.
Okay, I see a couple back there.
Uh, yeah, I think they're coming to you
with a mic
six. I can just Yeah. Could you have
distilled without synthetic? So, the
question is, could we have distilled
without synthetic data? Um, I think we
would have preferred to distill without
synthetic data, right? I think the the
use case that like the perfect case here
is the engineers come to us and they're
like, "Hey, we want to get this model to
be really really fast and we have a
thousand labeled examples." And we're
like, "Great, we'll get back to you in
like a day." Um, instead, this is what
we had to do. But yeah, that's a that's
a good question. I think there's one
back there.
Yeah. So the question was what was the
ratio between synthetic and slightly
less synthetic data and how many
examples did we need? Um I think I'll
answer the second one first which is
and we we I have this in a demo and
we'll like we'll look at the
performance. So like um at around like
50 to 100 examples you start to see
signs of life. um and that might be like
already enough for some smaller
problems. Then if you start like pushing
more toward production, you might want
to scale up to like few hundred 500
examples. In the demos I have later, I'd
use 150 examples and 500 examples. Um
but this is for supervised fine-tuning.
For the other two kinds, you can
actually use uh fewer and it's more
forgiving and we will talk about that in
a second. Um and then the first one was
what is the ratio? I don't remember. I I
think I tried some ablations where like
I only provided one of the um one of
each and like um it was best when I
provided both together but I can't tell
you what I I don't remember what the
ratio was.
Yep. Okay. So you you said that there
was around 100 functions. Yes. Okay.
Yeah. I pretty much had the same
question. So you're you're basically
saying for each function you had around
50 to 100 synthetic examples.
Uh I don't remember. It was I I've said
a lot of numbers around 100 and 500, but
I I think they're being maybe conflated.
We had 100 functions around 100
functions. Each one we generated um I
think it was like between 20 and 200
like we tried different amounts like
between 20 and 200 examples depending on
how many permutations each function
would give us. Mh. Um
and then also depending on which which
of the inputs. So all in all, I think it
was in the like like high hundreds, low
thousands, maybe like Yeah. low to mid
thousands of examples that we used.
Yeah.
And sorry if I'm skipping ahead here,
but was there um did did that improve
the function call accuracy for like
choosing which function to call or did
it just improve like how well it would
call a function?
So like choosing the function versus
like populating the function parameters.
Yes, both. It improved both. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, we um if I remember correctly,
we got to like within 2% of GPT4 at like
a very small fraction of the latency.
Yeah. Uh something else that we tried
was like what happens if you remove all
the context uh all the functions from
context or like the parameters from
context like can it learn the parameters
like because we wanted to like really
squeeze out as much context as we could
to like reduce latency. And you know
when you're cutting input context for
latency reductions, you're like like
you're out of options, right? You should
never start with that. But we were
trying everything. Um and that was
actually not very good results. We we we
realized like having things in context
like removing them from context makes
them much harder to learn through
fine-tuning. It's not as um as good.
Thanks. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So how followup questions
there in the future if they have more
functions
then do they need to retrain everything?
uh let's say they have 100 and you know
they just have two more. Yeah. So they
would not scale right. I believe this
this does not scale in that way. If you
if you like add new functions you like
in this exact setup that we have you
would need to to retrain. Um there are
ways to just pick up training from where
you left off like you can fine-tune an
already fine-tuned model. Um and it just
continues the fine-tuned process
essentially. Would that be okay? Like if
you fine tune on top of this with few
examples. Uh I feel like it it could be
especially for this case. It's so
constrained. I feel like you can get
away with a lot in cases that are this
constrained. Yeah. I'll take maybe one
one more and then we will keep going.
Yeah. How did the prompts change?
How did the prompts change? Uh how did
the prompts change when I did this?
I see. Uh yeah in terms of so I think um
the question is around like how much we
managed to reduce the prompt size and
like context that we put into the model
the answer is a bit but not that much
like we were able to get rid of most of
the prompt and just say like classify
into like one of these and then here's
all the functions but we weren't able to
remove like types or the different parts
of the functions themselves um from the
context without losing performance.
Yeah. which was much more of an issue
then because we were working with like a
4K context window. Uh it was maybe maybe
I think we like had to like push like uh
applied to like let us fine-tune a 16k
model and it was it was crazy. Now it's
like you fine tune like 1 million models
no problem. Okay. Um cool. This is this
case. I'll move on and we'll have we
have plenty of time for questions. Um,
and if you're more if you're curious to
learn more, we did actually write a lot
of this up in uh a cookbook called
fine-tuning for function calling. Uh,
you can run it, you can play with it. It
has most of what I talked about.
Okay. Uh, time for the first live demo.
So, let's say we have a customer. I I
wanted to find um a data set that would
be easy to find. So
here I have cursor
um with like a very basic you know
loading in open keys yada yada yada but
then I'm loading in this banking data
set and essentially what it does if we
like print out um
the first thing in the data it's not
happy.
Oh,
cool. Um, we have some input text. You
know, I'm still waiting on my card. And
a label. And the label is uh some like
index into an array of
labels, right?
uh
of like actual text labels like um
uh user is not waiting for a card but
like like arrival time or something like
that right and so what we want to do is
we want to get a model that can like
classify this really really well and
this is a good case for fine-tuning or
for supervised finetuning it's very
straightforward um it's very direct uh
and it's very constrained right so okay
so here I load in the data I load load
in the label names. I guess I could have
just
printed these.
Cursor abandoned me today. Okay. Yeah.
Activate card. Yeah. Yeah. We got like
many of them. And so, as you can see,
this is not like a super easy task for
the models. This is like a lot of
different labels they can pick from. Um,
and this is as hard as I tried my
prompt.
That's it. That's it. Um, and then it
passed it all the labels. Um, and I
guess this is a good time to say in
supervised fine-tuning your prompt does
not matter as much, right? You are
showing like a direct uh like a direct
examples and so it like you can skip a
lot of the prompt engineering. Not all
of it, right? If you give it like
nothing to work on, it's not going to
like learn very well. Um, but like or
sorry, you could actually completely
remove your prompt and if you have a
constrained enough example, it will
still learn to do the right thing. This
is not true about DPO and RFT. You still
need good prompts for both of those. um
SFT I would recommend having at least a
decent prompt. Okay, so we have our
data, we have a label names, I loaded in
the test data. Uh and I wrote my prompt.
So now I have my messages. Uh I'm using
the chat completions API because
fine-tuning right now I think works in
that format. So I want to keep the
format consisting consistent. Um so we
have our system prompt which is this
beauty and then the user is just the
input text. the the user messages as
just the input text, right? And then I
write this very simple function that
calls the API
and gives a classification, right? And
so if I like test this out right now,
um, look at that. So, how do I look at
my card? Card arrival.
I guess that's correct. But like if I
run it a few more times, you know, card
not working. Like
it's not good to be fair. I don't know
if any of us could do this with this
prompt. Uh it's pretty bad, but that's
part of the point. Okay, so we have this
sort of like inconsistent thing. Um now
before we even start doing fine-tuning,
we have to ask like you know should we
do it? Right? And this is one of the
most important questions in fine-tuning.
I think this is part of why a lot of you
are here. Should I do it? The answer is
how well is it doing on your evals?
Right? So I wrote this very small like
parallel evaluation function um that
essentially takes in a model string, a
system prompt, uh some like input
samples to run over in parallel and then
a number of workers since I'm like
shooting them off in parallel sort of
like asynchronously. Um I have a 74 just
so I don't like violate and like rate uh
rate limits or like the number of
workers that I have is like fixed. um
I'm like logging the progress and then I
have my score function which just calls
classify intent um updates the progress
and then returns whether it equals the
correct label and I shoot them off in
parallel
and there we go. So uh this is my
evaluation function. You know people
talk about like different uh eval um
platforms we have a way to do evalware
as well on our platform. Um, I think I'm
going to stick to this for this example
since I want to keep things like mostly
in this notebook. Um, and we can like
see little pretty progress bars that I
made. Okay, so now we have GBT uh 40
mini and 40.
This will come in later. Uh, and we can
run it, right? And so if we run the
evals, we're essentially taking the
testing set um made up of 150 examples.
Uh, running it. My progress bars aren't
working correctly. That's fine. Uh, it
still finished, right? So, it just ran
40 mini and it ran 40 and now we get the
relative accuracies which is 75%
accuracy for 40 mini and 83% for 40. So,
you know, not bad. Let's see if we can
do better.
Um,
cool. So, this is just I'm taking the
actual data sets and then dumping them
out into files that we can use for
training. Now, if the important part
here is the format. So, the format of a
fine-tuning model and like let me see if
I can just I I just love pulling up docs
and talks. Uh it's it's what everyone
else will be doing. Um let's see.
Oh, by the way, you should all check
this out. Agents SDK TypeScript came out
today. Uh
where are we? There we go.
So, if we look at the format, by the
way, I know this stuff. I'm not doing
this for me, okay? This is for everyone
to see. Uh,
cool. So, here we go. This is the JSON
L, which is just like JSON lines, data
format that you you'll want to be
passing, which is um a messages uh
array, like a field. It's array that
you're used to, the one you know and
love. Um, and all it's going to do is
it's going to take the last assistant
message and learn from it. Um, here the
last assistant message is a function
call. So it has like the whole schema.
Um, but if we look at the data that
we're producing here,
these are like, you know, this is my
amazing prompt. Uh, these are like the
this is all part of the prompt, right?
And then when I get to the very end, oh
boy. Okay. Uh then we just have so
that's the developer message. Then we
have the user message which is the input
and then the assistant message which is
what we want it to respond. Um and
that's the whole setup and what it's
going to do is it's going to learn from
that last message. Uh so we can either
shoot this off from the uh fine-tuning
UI but I am going to show you I'll show
you how to do both. Um cool. So now what
we're doing is we're taking the data set
putting in this format and saving it and
calling it train. uh we then like upload
the files. So it's important that we
like for for us to reference files
within a fine-tuning job, we have to
upload them to the openi API first. So
clientfiles.create,
we have to set the purpose to fine-tune.
Give it the file. Here are the file ids
that we have. And now fine-tuning is as
simple as like this API call, right? We
pass in the base model. Uh the reason I
had the mappings between like the base
model like 40 and like the full snapshot
is because it can't take in um aliases.
It has to take in like the full
snapshot. Then we pass in the training
file which is going to actually train
on. Validation file which is going to
tell us how well it's doing uh so it
doesn't overfit. And then I'm just
passing in the number of epochs. There's
many more parameters you can play with.
I just want to give you a sense. Um so
cool. I already ran this. I don't want
you all to sit here waiting. Uh
fine-tuning jobs can take anywhere from
30 minutes and this is uh on the opening
API. Anywhere from 30 minutes to 24
hours. So give yourself time. Never do
this right before a talk. Uh cool. So we
have our fine-tuning job. Then we load
the model, right? We like check the
model. Uh we we check the job. We see if
it succeeded. We load them in. I
actually already saved them here. And
now the question is how well did it do?
I fine-tuned um as you can see I made
some examples with I guess I skipped
over this but I made some examples with
150 examples and I made some with 500
and I trained both four uh GPD 40 and
GBD 40 mini with each one just to do
like a little comparison.
Uh, and so I ran it and I also compared
it against 04 and 03 and the final
results at the very very end. This is
what they look like. So, uh, baseline
83% 75%. Uh, reasoning models a little
bit better, 80 and 90. Um, but the
fine-tuning models blow everything out
of like blow everything else out of the
water. Um, and this is kind of to to
show like how convenient fine-tuning can
be, right? like it's doing better than
03 at a task that like I barely wrote a
prompt for and I think even 40 mini yeah
40 mini with 500 examples is as is like
actually technically better than 40 but
like they they sort of re like are
reaching much higher levels so this is
what I want to show how you can like get
fine-tuning and like when it's worth it
now if this was something I could have
done with more prompt engineering maybe
but like this is a case where I have the
data I want to run it pretty
straightforward uh maybe Yeah, I'll
pause here again for for questions.
Yeah,
do the fine tune runs check for
overfitting and if they do, do they stop
or do you have to be like watching it
while you're like? Nope. So, the
question is, do the fine tuning runs
check for overfitting? No, they don't. I
mean, you can see it. You can see it on
like the diagrams. Let me see if I can
actually pull up these jobs. Um,
maybe this last one.
I guess the second question then is, do
you just kill it after the diagrams show
you that it's crappy or like how do you
know what to do next? Um,
am I in a different org? Okay, I may
have done this in a different org, so
I'll pull it up at a different time.
But, uh, yeah. Um, I don't want to leak
anything. Sorry. Uh sorry, what was the
question again? Do you have you do have
to you see the overfitting? Like what do
you do? Well, I mean, yeah, you you can
stop it and try again. Uh I think you're
asking me a very like data science
general question. What do you do when
you see overfitting? So many things you
can do. In this case specifically, it's
like, you know, you don't want to have a
24-hour job. Yeah.
Yeah, you can stop it. Yeah, you can
stop it. Uh you can stop it and I think
you'll still be able to test with latest
snapshot maybe. Uh right here. Here.
Yeah. Yeah. Hey, um, couple of
questions. How do you decide between
like when do you want to fine tune
versus not? Like do you lean to always
using 03? Like when do you sort of pick
up to like actually go find fine tune?
I'll I'll get into this more later, but
I think the short of it is always start
with prompt engineering and see how far
you can go and then run evals, right?
And so if if it's as good as you want it
to be, that's great, right? Um, and if
you if you are still changing the prompt
and you are still getting better
results, there's no reason to fine-tune
yet, right? I think fine-tuning is
something you want to consider like when
you have enough data for it to be worth
it and the data is like pretty clean and
like
it's not really like a h like you kind
of have to have like the the the
resources ready for to do the
finetuning. Fair enough. And then like
which models do you like support fine
tuning for right now? Like does it keep
changing over time? Like I know it used
to support like you know 3, five and
then four. Like is everything like when
it comes out like instantly going to
support fine tuning or is there like
what's the lag period behind it? I think
we have
[Laughter]
Oh man. Uh where are we? I think we now
like say yeah which ones support
fine-tuning on the models page. This is
why I like docs and live browsers. Uh
yeah. Did you have to do any uh
hyperparameter tuning? Not for this. Uh
not for this. Yeah. Does it have any
impact on the results like updating
running late? Sure. But I'd say that
falls into the like the the c the the
field of like it's going to it's going
to be
uh very case by case. You have to like
run different different things. There's
not a lot of good intuition that I have
built that I can share with you. Um, but
I'm sure if you like look online,
everyone will have their own opinions.
Yeah. Thank you. Yeah. I'm curious on um
after you fine-tune, can you still tweak
the system prompt or if you do, do you
need to then fine-tune again? Yeah,
that's a good question. You can tweak
the system prompt, but um you are now
out of distribution and you are sort of
hoping the model was able to learn from
your like
enough out of distribution behavior that
it won't. I would recommend if you
fine-tune with a prompt, always use that
prompt. If you're going to change the
prompt, fine-tune again. Um, or just
like use many different prompts during
your fine-tuning. You don't have to use
just one. Uh, if you use multiple
different prompts, you might like you
might prevent it from collapsing too
much into like one specific kind of
behavior. Um, but good question.
Uh, yeah.
Yep.
fine-tuning for 40 mini
for
40.
Uh,
well, yes, that's a good question. I
don't know what happened.
I think um either I made a mistake or I
um
I would love to pull up the graphs right
now. Uh the reason I'm not is because
they I think I ran these on the OpenAI
or I don't want to pull that up on
screen live. Um but that's what I
recommend you do. Yeah.
Uh yeah. Um, regarding like overfitting,
do you have like uh ergonomics to do
that in the SDK? Like like defining test
set and then Oh, yeah. Yeah. I mean, you
you can define a test set validation set
and it'll like you can determine when
when you see the like the curve go up of
like the test set like when you see them
cross to stop a job or you have to check
it. I guess I can just pull up like an
old older one. Um I just don't know how
successful they'll be. But like you know
you get these
what what was I doing?
Yeah. But like the blue line is
validation loss and the green one is
this is clearly like not an amazing
fine-tune run. I think this was pretty
old. But this is like what the graphs
look like. Yeah. Okay. Uh I'm realizing
uh we still have a lot left and I'm
running out of time. So, let's keep it
chugging along. Um,
cool.
Okay. So, rules of thumb for supervised
fine-tuning, it's best for simple tasks.
Um, models can regress on other tasks.
So, I mean this regression that you
called out confusing. I'm not sure what
it was. Um, and but the thing is if you
if you then test it on different things
that you did not fine-tune for, you may
see regressions. So, this is for very
constrained cases. Data diversity is
critical for that reason. Anything you
don't include might regress. Um 100
samples to start 500 plus is best. Okay.
DPO uh training a model on jokes. Uh
so
my my my thinking here was like if we
take a model like jokes like this
funniness principle is like very hard to
evaluate for but you know between two
options whether something is funny or
not. So this feels like a good candidate
for DPO. Uh so I generated a bunch of a
bunch of jokes for with 4.5 hoping they
were going to be good. Um most of them
were not. Some of them were. Uh I really
wanted a data set and this is really
what it comes down to. All of these are
about the quality of data. I did not
have high quality data. I had some
medium quality data with a um like
mediocre validator. So like uh then did
some manual filtering like did I laugh?
Did I did I exhale a little bit more?
And then um okay, the interesting part
is once I have this subset of good jokes
uh which really should have been like a
nice data set. Uh remember what we're
trying to do, right? We're trying to get
some inputs and then two pairs. So I
went backwards again from joke. I
extracted the topic.
Um and once I had the topic for each
joke, I once again went forward uh with
40 and asked it to like generate a corny
joke for that topic. Um, and so what
we're left with is once again input
topics and then good jokes and bad jokes
for that topic. Um, and so hopefully the
like main delta between those jokes is
going to be one is good, one is bad.
They're about the same topic. So like
that delta should be stronger. Um, as
opposed to just giving it two unrelated
jokes. Maybe it's like ah like you know
he's looking for like cat jokes or
something. No, it's like similar jokes.
One's funny, one is not. Um, did it
work? sort of. Um, this is one of the
results that I got. So, two guys are
hunting when one collapses, suddenly,
stops breathing, and appears lifeless.
Panicked, his friend calls emergency
services, "Help! My friend collapsed.
He's not breathing. I think he's dead.
What should I do?" The operator calmly
replies, "Stay calm. First, let's make
sure he's really dead." And there's a
short silence followed by a loud
gunshot. Then the guy comes back on the
phone, "Okay, now what?" Okay, so
is it original? I don't think so, but
like you know it's funny. Uh, cool. So,
um,
yeah, but like can you tell me an
original joke right now? It's exactly
that joke. Exactly that joke. 10 years
ago.
I agree. Me too. I would say almost all
the jokes that the models generate like
you are hardressed to make like a good
one. But I think it's still like it's
not a null result because the fact that
it was able to like give me a good joke
on command is a hard thing to do, right?
Like I think if you ask Chatbt for a
good joke now, it's like harder to get
that to happen. So even though these are
like not new jokes, the idea is to like
elicit the good jokes. Um what was I
going to show you? Where's my notebook?
Um
yeah, so here is the data in the format
that we said, right? So we have the user
input, then tell me a joke about topic,
and then we have the preferred output,
and then the not preferred output.
Amazing. Cool. Let's keep going.
Um, okay. So, DPO, it's more forgiving
about data diversity because if you give
it like a bunch of examples that are all
specifically jokes and then I ask for
like um a speech about something, um,
it's not going to give me a joke
necessarily, right? Because it didn't
learn to say jokes, it learned to get
funnier hopefully. Um, so it's like that
delta is is important and it is less
constraining than SFT. Um,
it's it's much more for like these what
do you prefer scenarios and like it's
harder to evaluate unless you have like
humans or like some like natural signal.
Um, and you can actually run it after
SFT. Okay, reinforcement fine tuning.
The one I wanted to save time for which
I didn't. I still have some time. Um the
shape of it as we talked before this is
I think a pretty exciting one is like as
time goes on um I think more and more
use of this is going to is going to
start happening because this is the
first way um that I see that like we are
really making this algorithm public like
this reinforcement learning algorithm
public and you can like become like get
soda like state-of-the-art results on
whatever your task is um like beyond
um Cool. So what does this algorithm
look like? You have a bunch of inputs.
Give it to the model. Model for each of
the inputs generates this like chin of
thought to the output. Then you have
your greater. Your greater evaluates the
results, right? Um how does it do this?
However you want. Uh and we'll get to
that in the next slide. But importantly,
when it performs well, it reinforces
those behaviors specifically and
whatever led to that chain of thought.
And so good chain of thoughts um that
like get high scores are more likely
like to to to keep going like to it's
more likely to generate those change of
thoughts that lead to high results which
is exactly how like 0103 and these
reasoning models are trained in the
first place. So you can do this. Um
now these are the very very important
things to keep in mind. You want to have
unambiguous grading. Um, in an example
you'll see later, the grading was a
little bit less uh unambiguous and the
results varied. Um, you want very low
not and by unambiguous it just means
like if you ask a bunch of people uh who
are like fairly smart and have the same
rubric how to get to the answer, they
will all give you the exact same answer.
Um, you want very low noise data. So if
you have like any mistakes in your data,
they're going to like magnify in a way
that is not normal for like SFT and DPO.
So, it's very very very important for
you to clean your data and not have like
noisy signal. You want you want it to be
high signal like and this kind of goes
with the last one. You want it to be
able to actually get to the solution. Um
because it's learning to reason. It's
not necessarily learning like new facts
or like new new things. It's like it's
learning how how to get to the solution.
Um,
and because it is like so it's it's very
data efficient, you can give it like 40
to 80 very high quality, very high
signal examples and it can like learn to
reason over them and generalize uh to
other examples in that set.
Uh, cool. So now let's talk about
graders. Uh, there's a whole myriad of
graders you can pick from. There's
string like string checks. Um, there's
text similarity. Um, you can write
Python code sandboxed, no internet
access. a few libraries pre-loaded. Um,
and you can have that Python code be the
grader itself. You can have uh score
like model graders. So model graders are
just like the like using the LLM with a
prompt. Um, one that outputs a score,
one that outputs a label and we have a
multi-grader. You can nest these as much
as you want and then you write a
combination function. Um, and so this is
how you can define the grader. I'd say
it covers most of the cases where you
would want to have something graded. Um,
and you can get pretty pretty good
results.
So, uh, this was my idea for the talk.
Um, I hate email. Let's make a model
that can, uh, do the thing like I, it's
not that I wanted to respond to email.
It's I want to know whether it has to
show it to me or whether I can ignore it
and never have read it in the first
place. Uh, so that was the idea. So, I
made this little like email labeler for
myself and I became a little data
labeling
person for a day. Um, turns out if you
make an interface that is nice, you can
go so much faster. Um, so I labeled
around 600 emails. Uh, my my categories
were like, uh, am I going to glance,
ignore, archive it, which is like
receipts, store it, which is like I want
to see it later, respond within
different time frames, take action
within different time frames. I actually
didn't end up using the topic.
Um, and I can download it as a JSON L.
Now, what do the instructions look like?
I have some formatting. I have some
classification instructions with like a
little bit of extra instructions, but I
didn't try very very hard with this
prompt. This will come back to bite me.
Um, and then the input itself, I
formatted as um like this like XMLish.
So I wrapped it each in an email. The
input is in an email with sender,
subject, date and then the stringified
body uh plain text of the email.
How um yeah so this is then I formatted
the data for reinforcement fine-tuning
which is a set of messages in the same
way that you would for SFT or all the
others. Um and then I use reference
answer. You can use any other fields
that you want, but that is essentially
uh fields that are accessible to your
greater. Uh and then the greater, which
I defined below, uh is just a string
checker that takes the uh reference
answer action and compares it to the
sample output. And if they're equal,
we're we're good. Um now, how'd it go?
Like okay,
not amazing. Um and I h I I I think I
know why, right? So first of all, like
this is just my whim. Like I was like
whi whimsy deciding whether an email is
important or not. It's a very hard
function to model. If I were if I was
asked to label the same emails again,
would I hit like a 100% the same
classifications for all of them?
Probably not. And that's exactly the
scenario you want to avoid. Um it was
somewhat noisy. I think I like screwed
up like one or two. Uh and that like uh
compounds. Um 150 examples that was
actually fine. like if they were a very
high signal, this would have been like a
better result, but they weren't. Um, and
I didn't really try with a prompt. The
model doesn't know what I want and it's
trying to figure it out. It's like it's
like as if I gave you this task with the
emails and I locked you in a room and
you get to like maybe write some notes
uh and I like slip you some food and
water. Um and then the greater uh you
know streaming quality that was fine but
there's only like a few categories so
the model could guess some and you
wanted to make it not uh very guessable.
Um okay so that was my failure. Now
let's take a look at something that like
reinforcement fine tuning is actually
quite good at right. So um predicting
the number of hydrobond uh sorry yeah
hydrobond I think it's yeah hydrobond
donors and acceptors. Um this is
actually fully out of what I understand.
Um but the model can learn to do this
quite well. So the task is to take in
some chemicals um format in a specific
format and then predict the donors and
acceptors uh to analyze it. And this is
an example of one of the inputs. Um now
the output schema is defined on the
left. We have acptors and donors uh
which are just two numbers and it just
has to output these two fields. And then
on the
right uh I have my greater which is a
multi-grader. It just checks for each of
them right and the weight is gets half
if it gets the donor right half of gets
the accepter right. Um I'm going to
pause here because this is an important
slide if there's any clarifying
questions otherwise I'll move on.
Amazing. Um so what were the results?
Much better. This started at roughly
like 65%.
Um it ended up going to I think it
started like touching 80%. Right? And
this is 04 mini. Um 04 mini like does
not have a very vast world knowledge. It
really has to like learn to reason
through things. Um I'd say even this
result is not like fully exemplary of
how good it can get. The reason it's not
as good is because it does need some
world knowledge to understand um like
this sort of simulation that you have to
do with the hydrobonds. Um but you still
see this like very very high performance
that it like you would not get with
something like supervised fine tuning.
Yes. Can you use DPO for this? Could you
like do your email with DPO first and
then do this? Yeah. One thing I forgot
to put in the slides. SFT and DPO you
can do with non-reasoning models. RFT
you can do with reasoning models and
there's no interplay. Can you repeat his
question? Yes. Sorry. He asked um if
there
I'm blanking
whether you can do DPO before RFT and
the answer was uh SFT and DPO are for
non-reasoning models. RFT is for
reasoning models and it's like an IFFF.
Um cool. So some thoughts on uh notes on
reinforcement finetuning only for
reasoning models. uh it's extremely
sensitive to noisy data. Um agentic use
cases are limited by a single turn,
right? So you can't yet have these like
long horizon tasks with multiple turns
and function calls. Uh and reinforcement
fine-tuning. I would love to see that.
We'll see if we ship it at some point.
And then um you want the data to be high
signal uh and you want a solid grader.
And if you provide both, you are likely
going to reach like state-of-the-art
performance on the task that you are
going after.
Um,
cool. So, this I think is one of like
the most telling slides. I believe
that is most of what I have for today.
Um, I have a notebook. I have a ton of
stuff that I didn't quite go through.
Um, I'm happy to dive into that, but I
kind of want to leave this open for
questions and like poking around um
different parts. Actually, how much time
do I have left?
An hour. Oh, great. We can do so much in
this time. Uh you guys are are captive.
Okay. Yeah, I I do want to do a little
quick questions and then we'll move on.
One thing I started and didn't do is
another kind of tuning. Um which I can
do live, which is prompt tuning. Um
which I'm going to make up on the spot.
So if you want to see that, stick
around. Um but yeah, questions. Yeah.
Yeah. Hi. Uh so I had a small question.
Uh so you're saying that if I have a
non-reasoning model and let's say I do
an SFT step with it uh can I induce
thinking into it? For example, if I
create a data set input output pairs
which has let's say thinking into it as
well. So would you call it the same
amount of thinking as you would get in a
u reasoning model? um you would get
thinking it's a very kind of a very
different kind of thinking because it's
it's purely it's learning by imitation.
Um so it's not learning to like uh
reason in order to get to an answer.
It's learning to imitate the thought
process. Um
regardless of whether it's actually
useful to it or not, right? Um however
on the other like whereas reinforcement
finetuning like it is it is the one
producing the chain and so like if it
gets to the right answer it means that
chain was useful like in in practice and
that is true for like every single time
that it gets reward it's because like it
managed to get there. So it's it's like
it's pretty different I'd say like yeah
SFT with a um reasoning is like what we
started to see a little bit like maybe a
year ago. Um but reinforcement uh
learning is really how you get like high
quality learning. Yeah. Like chains of
thought. Uh yeah. Y or sorry somebody
has a mic. Yeah. Here we go. Yeah. Um
thanks. Could you go back to the slide
um where you showed the inputs to the
RFT? Yeah. This one. Um the weights. It
does it. Um, so for the calculated
output, can I
um basically instead of just like a a
lookup into a dictionary, can I have
functions there like like to so so can I
pass in a a function to check if the
code runs and output a number or like a
one or a zero to see if it runs for
example? Um, can you can you say it
again? So if um I just thinking um one
of the guys in the team is fine- tuning
a model at the moment to write uh Triton
code and one of the checks he has is
like does the code actually run like is
it valid Python? Is it possible to
encode that as a grader? You could do
that in a hacky way. Yeah. Right. So you
could use like a u a python greater
and inject the model response like just
do like um eval or like exec which if
you've come to my previous AI engineer
talk I did the same thing don't do this
but you could you could uh get it to
work if it has a lot of right libraries
and doesn't need internet access which
it might not and um just the and then on
the the weights you have there does it
matter the
magnitude I guess of like what you're
calculating like should you should you
like aim for it to sum to to one or or
100 or like it doesn't really um massive
difference I don't think it matters yeah
yeah yeah um it asterisk in the way that
like
it it doesn't really matter asterisk you
can look into the asterisk yeah good
thanks
I want to do some in the back because I
feel like I've been missing some in the
back yeah yeah you you mentioned that it
wouldn't the RFT wouldn't work for
multi-step uh agent stuff. Could you
talk a little bit more on like why and
if if you if OpenAI were to make it work
for that what that would look like? I
just kind of didn't understand. Yeah.
Yeah. So, so the reason I said that um
is because right now it only does a
single turn and only evaluates the
output of the model. if the model say
like calls a function, there's no way to
provide it the result and let it keep
going, right? And so that's really what
you want for like an agentic evaluation
loop, which RFT does not currently have.
Um I I think that would be awesome if
like we did have a way to like um
provide the output of the model and like
do these more endto-end training. Um but
this is what we have right now. Gotcha.
Yeah. Thank you.
I want to do in the back first a little
bit. Yeah.
Yeah.
Check val
you know when do you need to design that
type of custom graater and when is a
generic grater sufficient? Yeah. So the
beginning of the question was in the
hydro bond example um we use like yeah
this this string checks when is it worth
using more complex um graders? I think
the answer is like where you think it
would benefit uh like is it a more
accurate score? Is it a higher signal
grade? Because if the answer is yes,
then you might actually just get higher
like better results, right? It's going
to maximize whatever this grader says is
good. And so if you can better tune what
that means, like what good means, you
will just get better results. Yeah. Um
or does someone else have the mic? Yeah.
Yeah. Uh can you tell us more about the
RFT algorithm or some details about
here? Here just come here. No, I'm
kidding. No. Um I mean it I think
obviously I can't share like the the
exact details but like it is it is
fundamentally like a very very similar
algorithm to the exact algorithm that we
used for 01 and 03 right like this
reinforcement learning with language
models is like exactly how we did our
reasoning models um and we are putting
as much out as we can right and so like
you can actually get these like really
really insane results um if you have
clean data in uh in your scenarios.
Yeah. The reason I I really wanted to
come with like a lot of really good
examples. The reason I can't come with a
lot is like a a lot of them are like
proprietary and I can't share and b I
wasn't able to do many myself because I
don't have a lot of really good data
that I work on. Um yeah. So back there.
So our time is our most precious
resource. Mhm. How do you determine when
fine-tuning is worth it versus
integrating with a new model or getting
better data?
Yeah, maybe this is a little bit of a
hot take, but I would avoid fine-tuning
until you need it. Um, right. Like if
you
um
if you can get away with prompting, you
should just use prompting. Yeah. uh and
fine-tuning the the way you actually
know sorry I blanked for a second um you
really want to evaluate right like if
you if your evals are showing that like
you are reaching the limits of what you
can accomplish through prompting but you
know it's better to do pos uh you know
it's possible to do better then that's
when you can pull out fine-tuning if you
have the data if you have everything set
up um it is a big upfront cost right but
if you if you are in a space like uh you
know legal or like uh in like um hard
sciences like it can really be worth it
to do something like reinforcement
fine-tuning because the results you get
are like impossible to achieve
otherwise.
I have a question. Uh what's happening
on the OpenAI platform side when we do
fine-tuning? So is it generating like a
new set of weights and then when you
actually go to run inference does it
load those weights into memory and run
on that or like how does that work?
Yeah. So it is generating new weights.
It's generating this Laura component,
right? So it's generating like this
little piece that we use with the
models. Um the rest of the weights are
the same in the model. And so what it
does when you use your inference is it
loads in that part of the weights and
then uses those. Yeah.
I had a question on DPO. Um how bad
should your bad examples be? Like with a
joke, should it be just barely bad, like
it's nonobvious and so you're squeezing
out nuance, or should it just be like
really bad? I I think you sort of
answered your own question, right? If
you make it too bad, then you are
learning um how to go from like really
bad to like good, which might not be
what you want to teach the model. You
might want to teach the model how to go
from like mediocre to really good,
right? And so yeah, like you want to
sort of mimic what you would expect to
see. um or or you want to think like
what is that um delta I I think I
haven't actually heard of too many other
people doing like synthetic DPO with
generated bad examples um most often
it's just used for AB tests because the
the signal from an AB test is real and
pure right the signal from synthetic DPO
is as good as your imagination
maybe and like your intuition
So I yeah like the best would be to like
actually have people sit in front
like sending everyone like a little
website and having labeled a bunch of
examples but then I realized even if we
did that I wouldn't be able to train it
live. Um but that would be that would be
like good real signal right perfect
signal for DPO.
Uh yes
you're going to have to yell. So I'm
kind of curious about why RF doesn't
work for models. Like say I wanted to
get a model that only produced output
precisely 30% emojis. I don't think I
could do that with
uh the question is
why RFT doesn't work with non-reasoning
models. What was the bit about emojis? I
missed that. Sorry.
If I wanted to get reasoning model
exactly I don't think I could do that
with
um
exactly is tough but I I would bet that
you could get somewhat close. Um I mean
it depends. Are you trying to do like a
if it's a very specific constrained
example? Sorry, the more general one was
an example for
reinforcement learning with nonreason
models might work. Yeah. Um wouldn't be
the main reason it doesn't work is
because we don't support it. Uh you
repeat question. Yes. So the question
the question is why doesn't
reinforcement finetuning work with
non-reasoning models? It's because we
don't support it. Yes.
Yeah, you have a couple of questions.
So, uh, so does does custom GPD you
have, you know, does it use one of those
fine-tuning custom GPTs? Yeah. No, no,
not just a prompt. Okay. And second
question is that uh for us certain
applications it's also important to have
good thinking coot you know. Yeah. But
looks like there's no reward for or
penalty or anything for that like if um
yeah I mean we released a paper recently
that talked about how you should avoid
um directly evaluate like directly
rewarding or penalizing certain
behaviors in your chain of thought
because if you don't touch the chain of
thought portion and only um put pressure
on the results um essentially you get
faithful chains of thought. you you you
can actually see um you hopefully close
to what the model is like actually
thinking through. Um and so if it's
doing something you might not want,
it'll be clear. Um but if you like for
example reward like investigate the
chain of thought and like penalize it if
it starts thinking about bad things um
turns out uh you do reduce the ratio
like the percentage of bad things by a
little bit but you reduce the cases
where you can catch them by looking at
the chain of thought to like zero and so
it's like not a good idea to do it.
There's a there's a paper on this you
should you should look it up we release.
So other question is uh you know like if
you have a really good training data
right then you can just distill the any
small models or even open source ones
right I believe so how so like
supervised training and you also show
DPO if you have a really good quality
data and where things are deterministic
especially the questions
then I believe there is no point in
going to bigger models like open AI
right any open source models would do
it. What What's What do you think about
that? You know, well, you know, if it's
if it's doing what you want, that's
awesome. Like, yeah, like go with every
go with whatever is going to get you the
performance that you're looking for. I
think just in practice, you know, the I
think the real consideration is like do
you want to fine-tune an open source
model and deal with like um like if you
have the data for it, that's amazing. If
an open source model does what you want,
use that. But if you're like if you have
the choice between like fine-tuning an
open source model um which involves all
the like pitfalls that I just talked
about versus just like asking 40 like
with no fine-tuning it's like
one of is going to let you move faster.
You can always start with a bigger model
and then like tune a smaller one. Right.
So I'd say always start with always
start with the biggest most expensive
thing that'll make your thing work and
then work on getting more efficient.
Yeah.
Yeah. Given uh the knowledge that you
shared with us uh today, can you give us
a little bit of insight why 03 scores
higher but uh hallucinates more than 01
in general? Like why 03 hallucinates
more than 01? Yeah, you have that on the
in the system card, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I don't have like a reason
that I can give you. I think that's
something we're investigating.
Obviously, it's something that we want
to avoid, but like um
yeah, I don't think we have like a super
solid like understanding we can share
about why that happens. Um and speaking
for myself, I don't know. Yeah.
Uh thanks a lot. This is great. Um it
seems like the hardest thing to do for
uh reinforcement learning is the reward
modeling or like defining the reward
functions. Do you have any heruristics
or tips or resources on like uh the
number of reward functions or like the
type of problems that it suits or
doesn't? I just feel like that there's
like not that much to know when I'd like
reach for reward functions now. And you
know how how I'd find that it's it's
it's almost like it's a a solution in
search of a problem. you know, I don't
know when I would when I would do this.
You know, when you would when I would
use reinforcement learning and like know
like find five perfect reward functions
that model some behavior I want want to
capture. Um yeah, I think
I think when it's not for a beginning of
the problem, right? Let's say you
already have something in place. It's
already working and like you're
wondering if you could do even better.
Like the fact that you're asking
yourself, can you do even better? Means
you already have a way to evaluate it
and already have a way to grade it. And
so that's the beauty of it. It's like by
the time that you're asking yourself
like should I use reinforcement
fine-tuning, you should already have all
the data ready or almost close to ready
because all you need is like your
whatever eval setup you have. Yeah. So,
so I have like a good LLM judge that I'm
using for evals and then I take that LLM
judge, I use it as a reward function to
to to fine tune. You can Yes. Okay. So,
that's the kind of path. It's like start
off build a good LM judge that captures
the task you want to do well on and then
you know try milk a model with like oral
to make it better. Yeah. I mean that
that's one way for sure and like if that
is the path that works for you that's
great. I wouldn't say there's one like
necessarily one path. So, actually in
the crowd is Teao. Can I can Can you
wave? So, um, he wrote a cookbook that I
used to base a lot of this examples for.
Um, you should check it out. It's I I
believe what's it called? Can you yell
at the name?
Exploring
I think it's exploring model graders for
reinforcement fine-tuning. Yeah. Yeah.
Incredible cookbook. You should all
check it out. It goes into like the
nitty-gritty of like how to do each of
these different parts. It talks about
different graders. It talks about like
all the different pieces. So, you should
really check out that cookbook and the
function calling one if you're curious.
I'll see if there's a way for us to send
it out. Maybe I can just like pull it up
real quick. Um
I think it's this one. Yeah. So, you
should really check this out. Um it's
long, it's comprehensive, and it's like
really good. Um Cool. Any Yeah. Uh, I
had a question here. Yeah. Uh, does the
fine-tune API support different
modalities as well or it's just text?
Oh, we do have image fine-tuning.
I forgot. Yes. Wow. Okay. We have image
fine-tuning. Uh, and so you can do image
input and um I believe it's text output.
So, it's really good for like bounding
boxes and all these other parts. Wow.
Thank you. It's like you're a plant.
uh stand up. Yes. Um so how do you um
teach model new knowledge or domain
knowledge? So and then how do you use
that work with the reasoning and and one
example is like if I have my personal
experience, personal preference, should
I do fine-tuning or should I kind of put
it in context? Um I would say always try
starting by putting things in context.
Um yeah, fine-tuning you want to like
leave for like a later stage thing. You
already you already have some data to
like show one way or another. Um in
order to like give models new knowledge,
you know, you have like all like
different ways you can do rag and
search. Um
technically when you fine-tune you can
put in small amounts of new information
into the models, but in general you
should treat it as more of a
methodology, right?
um like if you consider an algorithm
data like in that it requires bits to
describe the procedure, you're sort of
teaching that, but you you can't really
give it like um too too much data.
However, you it can it can learn a bit,
right? Like SFT starts to memorize
certain things that you give it. Um, I
just wouldn't say it's like the best way
to give like correct information or like
correct like referenced information. I'd
say maybe it's good to like I would
focus it more on formatting, you can use
it, right? like I think like two years
ago at this point um when we released um
fine-tuning for GPT3.5
one of the interesting things you can do
is um
if you do retrieval you can teach a
model like with um like embedding search
and you need to like embed the query
first sometimes you want to like
transform the user's query into
something that looks more like your
search results um I think it's like
hypothetical document embeddings. Um,
you can fine-tune a model to like do
like essentially hallucinate that
better, right? Like if you train it on
like the actual outputs like in your
actual like knowledge base, then it's
more likely to output something that is
in distribution um for your knowledge
base and so you'll get like more direct
mappings if that makes sense. So, but
but it's like you're not really teaching
it too much new information. It's just
helping you find it's giving you a
better intuition to find it. Yeah. So
like for for reasoning models sometimes
if I want to reference to custom
definition or custom custom knowledge in
certain domain is it good to kind of
combine with rag and then generate that
kind of training data train with RL or
or just like I guess that's in general
how to solve that problem um for that
case uh I would just let the model like
give the model some search functions.
Oh, like let the model do search. Um, if
you have explicit search steps that you
do beforehand, um, then you can maybe
fine-tune like specific parts, but we
like because search is like inherently a
two-step process. It's like searching
and then interpreting. You can't do that
with reinforcement fine-tuning right
now. I see. I see. Thank you.
Uh, so for your question, for your thing
about the email classifier, did you do
the reinforcement learning just to kind
of show us like a bad example or No, no,
no. I really hoped it worked. Oh, okay.
Uh, that was me. Well, it's so
ambiguous, right? And then you were
like, well, don't be ambiguous with it.
And I'm like, okay. Uh, okay. Yeah. No,
thanks for calling me out publicly in a
talk, but keep going. Well, I'm not
trying to do that, but I'm joking. I'm
joking. For the supervised fine-tuning,
that would have been the What was the
correct answer there then? Like
supervised fine-tuning given your data
set? Um,
so what I what I wanted to try and like
maybe if we have enough time I'll like
do a little bit of this was like there
are a lot of nuances around the email
that I h like my preferences that are
extremely low signal. Like I might see
it once, like I might get two very
similar emails from two very similar
like uh people uh or like like sources
and one I decide to like glance and one
I decide to like ignore. How is it going
to learn that, right? um like what I was
imagining is like if you find cases that
are similar and you could do that with
embeddings um but that have different
results you might be able to give them
to like a reasoning model and be like
you know figure out what's different
here and then make a note of it and then
you can compile this set of like
principles essentially that hopefully
guide what it does and so this is like
what I would consider almost like prompt
tuning where you like are finding the
right context to provide the model based
on a lot of examples.
Uh we can try and that would be cool to
see. uh like I feel like embedding
fine-tuning the embedding model itself
though would almost be critical then to
get right for an individual for an
individualized like why what how so why
because embeddings naturally don't
understand the nuance of like how you oh
no no I'm not saying using embeddings to
find case to like find the nuance I'm
saying use embeddings to find similar
ones right but how would it know what's
similar based on your preferences not
based on my pref preference based on
like
whatever embedding similar like does
like finding similar in the naive sense
and then showing the model sim like
naive similar cases that are actually
different and being like look these are
the embedding model thought these were
similar but they're actually profoundly
different for some nuanced reason what
that is that make sense yeah um yeah
feel like people kind of want to see me
try this. Okay, so I did start trying
this.
Um, I'm also going to try not to flash
too much of data because this is my
actual emails. Um, okay. So, I have the
email data set.
I'm loading it. I have this like eval
function. I have my instructions. And
then I just made a little like helper
that essentially I just did a little
like fancy evaluation loop where you can
define
an evaluator and you can
where's my code? Oh
yeah, I'm sorry. The eval model takes in
a run function that just returns a
result. This is where I'm going to pass
the model there. Takes an evaluate
function and then a data set of workers.
This is just like a generic version of
the other function I implemented. Um,
cool. And let's see how it was doing.
So,
you know, I have this prompt tried with
all the models. And what am I getting
right now for a mini is 58% 51% worse?
56 57. So, this kind of goes to show
there's no signal to learn right now,
right? uh it's kind of random or like
there's there's the very little signal
there. So
let's think about this. How would you do
this sort of prompt tuning? Um
maybe even without the embedding models
we can like do these. Oh, I think I
started writing an algorithm somewhere.
Where is it?
Ha, there we go. Look at that. Um so
this was sort of the idea that I had for
fine-tuning for prompt tuning was like
run a forward pass um then sample from
that training subset or or sorry split
up into mini batches run a forward pass
um
sorry split into mini batches each of
which has a training subset and a test
subset. run a forward pass on the
training subset and then reason over it
to see how it could have done better
um and then take that put it back in the
prompt and then use that run it forward
again on the test subset and then update
the prompt and keep going. Does this
make sense? I don't know. I'm kind of
like coming up with this on the spot so
we can see how it goes. Maybe before I
jump into this I want to make sure
there's no more questions before I like
lose myself here.
No. Okay. People want to see me.
Okay. So,
you know what are we going to do? Uh,
let's do training loop.
And yeah,
should we just do this? Let's let's do
one run, right? So, like we
we have some like mini batch
Um
and then we have training
and like
train test.
Yeah.
Now
if we have that
then I want to run a forward pass. So
for
is it just evaluate
I'll do this in a lazy way right now. So
sample and train
let's do results.
Okay. So
h
sorry the model was so fast cursor is
amazing. Uh okay so
yeah let's pretend that's correct. Okay
so we get train we get test we sample
train. Um,
we should, yeah, we should also have
some labels
here. Should we print what? One of
these. So, we have let's let's go let's
do this like more accurately. So, the
samples have an action and they have a
text.
So, for each sample,
we want to run it on
Does the model take in the whole thing?
Yeah, it takes in a sample. Okay. So, so
then this should
let's just let's start here. Um, you
know, process may batch of
like I don't know, let's do 20.
Do I want to print this? Well, let's see
if this runs correctly. If this works.
Okay. Um,
I'll risk one.
This is one of the worst ideas I've had.
Ah,
I didn't know you could do top level
awaits, by the way, in notebooks. It's
really nice.
Um,
yeah, this should be in parallel. I'll
just do 10 for now.
Did it Was it happy?
Uh, okay. So, it's just the results. So
maybe I want to append
like sample
[Music]
and then model output.
Okay. Wow. Very uh topical. And it it
what did it say? What was the output?
Was it ignore?
I don't know. That feels correct.
Um okay. So now we have our Oh, and then
what was the
actual Okay, wait. Let's print,
you know.
Uh let's dump it, right? Um,
huh, we have a blank inputs.
My package has
ignore us.
Okay. Okay. No, this is good, right? So,
we have Let me just like quickly
There's a lot of blank ones. Hm.
Uh,
it's I don't know what it's doing.
Whoa, whoa, whoa. Why is it still
running?
Okay.
Good call. Oh, this is so much more fun
with people like debugging with me.
[Laughter]
Okay.
Uh,
okay. So, how should we do this? Should
we like I guess we could just give the
entire mini batch to a model. That's the
easiest thing. And then just be like,
you know, what did like think about what
you got wrong and then give me some
notes.
Uh, so we'll have results and then we
can make a you know like
where is it?
you know um extract
insights
and then we can do uh
I'll use 03
Okay. Any prompt engineers want to shout
out some prompts? Let's see. So, we have
model
have the results. We'll say like you
know um
uh you are provided
a set of
results
um from a forward pass to a model.
Um
given these results task is to let's see
it doesn't need to know the format. um
is critical. These results follow
um
uh not not that fast.
[Laughter]
uh you know
um
um you know there's an app that's really
good at making fonts for you.
Yeah. Well, okay, here's the funny part.
So, there is a
um
uh it was actually with a with um I
helped create this uh prompt generator.
I just don't want to go that far because
then it's more for me to read.
Okay. Um gen to
you know emails outside of this batch of
results. Um
the duplicated
in general the output should be at most
one.
Uh
and then what's the last one? It's like
Is this uh oh uh you know do not
I'll do this here.
Make sure the sides do not
overfit
to the
current batch of results.
Should it be a JSON array? I'll keep it
as a string for now. Simple string.
Okay. So, now we have that. Let's see
how it does on this.
Um,
man, this is like Okay. yada yada yada.
What did I call it?
Extract insights. Maybe I'll give it
reasoning. I'll I'll do like that. And
then results.
Huh?
Okie dokie.
How do we feel about this prompt? I
don't know. I feel like everyone's kind
of just watching thinking this is going
to work. I don't think this is going to
work, but like it'll be an interesting
experiment.
Okay.
I'd say this is too long
process.
Um, okay. So,
let's run this on
some other ones.
And then let's take this
and use this as a negative example. be
like
[Music]
and I'm not using the exact same one for
anyone who
might point that out. Am I?
Hm. Maybe I was.
Well, it's fine. We'll see
in the meantime. Okay. So, let's say
let's pretend this is good, right? Let's
pretend this is good. Then what do we
continue doing in this in this process
mini batch? So, we
um so here we did the forward pass. So,
we did results. Um, and so now we can
say insights is await those.
I'll move that up.
What it say?
We can we can we can see we can work on
the prompt later.
Um,
so I'll take extract insights.
Move this up.
Now I have it in here. Okay. So now we
have insights. So now what do we do? Um
maybe we can do like a wild true. So,
so we get the insights
and then maybe let's actually let's
measure performance on tests. So, we can
do you know eval model.
This is correct. Valid sample.
Um, validated results.
Let's print these.
Let's skip this for now.
So, 0.6. So then I guess the idea is if
we keep doing this and putting it back
into the prompt,
it should get better
maybe.
And then I'll try with a bigger with a
bigger mini batch.
Well, you know what? Let's let's cheat a
little and try with both the
test and the train. So, you know,
uh,
test results and then we can see how how
much we're overfitting train results.
Um,
cool.
Okay. So, we have we're printing both.
We have our insights. And what we want
to do maybe just like we could just like
have a little portion that is
ready. So model
make model
of Oh, are we even passing in the
prompt?
Yeah, because it's default to that.
So we could,
you know,
always make a new model
instructions equals
you can say
that.
So at each and then we have a notes
that starts out empty
and then
we do instructions
plus notes.
I don't know you. What do people think?
What's going to happen?
Okay.
Are you okay?
No.
Very good call. Very good call. So, we
could just make the notes this
Um,
maybe I should print out what the notes
are each time.
So
while this happens,
I think the idea here would be Oh,
that's that's pretty surprising.
we're already doing pretty good. Um,
so yeah, I guess I have zero confidence
this is going to work, but I think this
style of approach can work, right? Where
um you can take and you can do this in
in like a treelike structure as well
where you can take um maybe subsections,
these mini batches and then let it
reason over the failures and then maybe
produce these insights. Then you have a
choice as to how you want to like um
aggregate those insights. Here I'm just
replacing the notes in within each mini
batch. And then the plan was to like um
append all the different nodes together
from all the different mini batches and
put it in the prompt and see if that can
um perform better. Why is it stopping?
Thank you.
Um,
I'll leave this up in case anyone sees
any other mistakes. This is good to have
there.
But yeah, uh, this is like the skeleton
of something that could be very
interesting. Obviously with a better
prompt, obviously with better pieces.
Um, but
yeah, I don't know. Any any questions,
ideas, thoughts? If not, I might just
like call it uh after we see what the
results are.
for this
for this. I'm making this up in front of
you.
Any examples that work for anything?
for this technique.
Well, so you're you're asking, are the
numbers moving? Not significantly. Okay,
I'm gonna call it. This this doesn't
work right now, but it's good. It's good
enough to like be an example. Um I think
to to answer your question about you
know what what are the good techniques
um for prompt engineering like if I can
share some I I think they've just been
changing so much there's many many many
like prompt engineering guides and like
what you would want to do is like
I guess you're you're asking both about
prompt engineering but maybe also
something like this prompt engineering
there's so many resources I'd say the
biggest one is just be clear and don't
have any like contradictions um and then
fuchet examples are really really good
um for something like this I'm like
making this up as we go. Uh I think like
again I think the shape of this is
something that can make sense. Um
I would have been very surprised if I
would have gotten any like good results.
Maybe I'll say like a few minutes after
trying to get this work but um yeah
question back there.
Yes.
So the question is can I explain what
the hell I'm doing here? Um, I think the
idea here is to instead of tuning the
model itself, um, tuning the the prompt
and specifically tuning a subsection of
the prompt that I'm calling notes that
essentially hopefully contains like
jotss about the emails that it's seen
and anything that they might have found
unintuitive about classifying that maybe
that's something I should include in the
prompt. And so the hope is that as it
sees more emails
uh like with the what it actually
classified it as and what it was
supposed to classify it as um
by using these reasoning models
hopefully extract some like explicit
insights of like oh you know like maybe
Alain like um wants to like you know if
if if he sees like a package has been
delivered um I this one was probably
glance. This is what I mean. Like my
data is very noisy. Um but like he will
want to like glance at like um Oh, I
said ignore.
Like I might want to glance at this
instead of like archiving, right? And so
like but but the question is like but
why? Right? I didn't say why. I'm just
saying what the correct answer is. Um
and this is why I thought RFT might be
might be good. But like this is way too
noisy and subjective. But that doesn't
mean you can't use reasoning models to
still extract interesting insights. So
the idea would be to like give enough
examples of both successes and failures
um that the model itself has done to a
reasoning model and have it come up with
like
notes or techniques that the model can
use to hopefully improve the next time.
Yeah. So the question is like can I use
this to identify pieces of information
that are missing and I think yes
absolutely and I think that's like very
important for even art like if you if
you do want to find tetune but even if
you don't like this this approach can
like tell you a little bit about your
data as well. Yeah. So, like just it's
like having someone read through it um
and like write these things. Yeah. Um if
there's more questions, I'm happy to
keep answering. Um otherwise, I'm going
to officially call this. You have now
seen two failures today, but that's
okay. We learned from those. Um so,
thank you
[Music]